[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The cloud is an instrument.
It's a tool, a way to create,
to connect, and find patterns.
It's capable of many
things, but in your hands,
it can take your idea and
turn it into a reality.
We started investing in our
cloud over a decade ago.
Since then, we put more
into it than anyone else.
Now, it's more powerful, more
precise, and more capable.
We're excited to
share what it can
do with you when you plug in.
Because that's why we're
all here, to transform ideas
to apps and services,
to build things
that millions and
billions can use,
to invent tomorrow
without constraints,
to be free to create
and collaborate,
to be part of what's
now and what's next.
[END PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Thank you very much.
And once again, good
morning, everyone.
And welcome to GCPNEXT Tokyo.
First of all, I would like to
say a few words to kick off
this event.
At Google, I am in charge of
the Google Cloud Platform, head
of Google Cloud Platform.
My name is Shioiri.
Usually, I am called as KJ,
so maybe in the session,
I may be called as KJ.
But thank you very
much to have so many
of you sitting
here in this room.
And also, we have some audience
connected through online.
And I once again thank you very
much for your participation.
Well, in hindsight,
four years ago
I was engaged in the first
event for the GCP in Japan.
And there are 20
people who participated
in that event four years ago.
Next year, following year,
we had a cloud load show,
and it's about 200
people participating.
And last year, we actually had
our first NEXT event in Japan,
and it was 700.
And this time, this year,
the number of the restoration
is over 2,000.
So I think all of
you who are here,
and also all of you who are
connected through online,
well, every year, the
business, and also,
your passion or your support
make this event possible,
me standing here on stage.
Thank you very much
for your support.
So today, I hope that the
momentum on this Google
Platform, and also our
passion on this platform,
I hope that you use
this tag, hashtag,
and try to really communicate
what you hear or learn
at this event.
So without further ado,
we'd like to move on
to the first keynote address.
From Asia Pacific, the Managing
Director, Rick Harshman.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Rick.
RICK HARSHMAN: Konichiwa.
Good morning.
Thank you for choosing to
spend your day with us.
We're very excited
to have you here.
So welcome to NEXT Tokyo.
We've been running NEXT
events all over the world
to give the Google
Cloud Platform
community an opportunity to
connect and to learn, not only
with Google, but
hopefully, with each other.
We've come so far since the
last time we were here a little
more than one year ago.
We've launched hundreds of
new services and features,
like Cloud Machine
Learning and Kubernetes.
We've also announced
many global customers,
like Spotify, Walt
Disney, and Coca-Cola.
Cloud is central to everything
that we do at Google.
And we're investing
to make it the best
possible platform for new
and existing applications.
As Ruth Porat, our CFO,
at our last earnings call
said, "Cloud is central to our
investment strategy overall.
It is one of the
biggest bets that we
are making as a company."
The magnitude of that investment
is evident in our capital
expenditures.
At nearly $10 billion,
Alphabet's investment
is about twice as big as
other industry providers.
And the bulk of that investment
is technical infrastructure
to power the business.
And cloud growth is
accelerating across the board.
It is one of the most
exciting businesses,
not only inside Google, but
across the world as a whole.
Our core infrastructure
businesses
are growing at significant
multiples annually.
And when we introduce
a new feature,
like Container Engine or
Kubernetes, it just takes off.
And the momentum is
building locally, as well.
Let's just start with the Google
Cloud Platform user groups
that many of you participate in.
In the last year alone,
we've seen a 3x increase
in user group participants.
We now have over 3,300
members across 12
different Japanese cities.
And we also are offering
up local language
Japanese support, which we know
will be critical as we continue
to grow and scale the business.
The momentum is also building
across our partner ecosystem.
We've doubled the
number of partners
here in Japan, many of which
are here with us today,
as well as our global partners,
Intel, Red Hat, and Fastly.
We're honored to be
able to work with some
of the most well-known
Japanese systems
integration companies,
companies like JSOL,
who recently announced that
Mitsui Sumitomo Bank is working
with them to launch an
application on the Google Cloud
Platform; or a more
recent partner, NRI,
who's been chosen by Fuji Xerox
to build and run applications
on the Google Cloud
Platform; as well
as partners like Groovenauts and
our training partner TOPGATE.
We've also seen tremendous
growth around our revenue
here in Japan.
It continues to grow by
triple digits year over year.
And what's exciting
to see is that we've
seen that revenue increase
year over year to 220%
growth in the last year alone.
The Google Cloud is global
and based on a global network.
Our massive investment in points
of presence around the world
are shown here.
This means that
using Google Cloud,
you are connected to customers
anywhere in the world.
We have 50% more points of
presence than any major cloud
provider.
And that we're also investing
here, specifically, in Japan.
As many of you may know, we
pre-announced a Japanese data
center located here in Tokyo.
The last pieces of
the Tokyo data center
are coming together.
Here's what we've
finished already
in the Tokyo data center.
The hardware is in-country,
and we've burned it in.
We've provisioned the
resources, and we've
started basic services.
And we've put that new hardware
under a load to give it a test.
The last step is to
bring in customers.
So let your Google
Cloud Platform
team know if you're interested.
And if you're interested, please
sign up here to learn more.
I'll leave that
up for one moment.
So why are customers choosing
the Google Cloud Platform?
Well, we're seeing
an acceleration
in the number of customers
choosing the platform.
And Google Cloud Platform
isn't about using the cloud
to do the same thing that
you've always done, just
in a different place.
It's not an adaptation
of another technology
built with an old set of
assumptions and constraints.
As an aside, some
of you may know
about the amphicar, described
by one owner as the fastest
car in the water and the
fastest boat on the road.
It had a top speed of 7
miles an hour in the water.
This is the ultimate
example of lift and shift,
or maybe lift and float.
But we're interested in doing so
much more with the Google Cloud
Platform.
It's purpose-built and
tuned for cloud computing,
like these foiling catamarans,
provides a combination
of high-performance networking,
scalable data services,
granular flexible
infrastructure,
all working together to
change not just where
you do computing, but how.
Lift and shift becomes
lift and transform.
Transform how you do IT.
The Google Cloud
Platform is profoundly
different than other cloud
offerings in the market.
It's built to a different
set of standards,
and formed by Google's
own velocity, experience,
and culture of innovation.
And to explain why
this matters to you,
I'd like to introduce Cornelius
Willis, who leads our product
management efforts globally.
Cornelius.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Good job.
Good morning.
Konichiwa.
Most people understand
Google as a search engine,
as access to information.
If you're a business
person, you know
that Google operates an
advertising business.
But if you're an IT
professional or developer,
if you're in this room today
or watching on the live stream,
you know that Google is an
infrastructure business,
as well.
We've been in the infrastructure
business for 17 years,
since we started the company.
Including the
infrastructure behind me,
the data center is built on 14
campuses around the world, data
centers that are so purposefully
engineered for cloud computing,
they're not really
even buildings anymore.
They're really computing
appliances in their own right.
And our goal with this
infrastructure since we started
has been the same, to make it
easy to create great software
and operate it globally,
securely, and reliably.
Whether we were indexing
the world wide web
or creating a three
dimensional map of the world,
annotated down to
the street level,
or whether we were predicting
in real-time what a user would
type in the search box,
our product ambitions
have forced us to
innovate infrastructure,
reinventing hardware,
software, and even
our culture to keep up.
This constant pressure to stay
ahead of our product vision
is what's shaped what's next for
cloud, Google Cloud Platform.
Today, we're going to talk
about what's next for cloud.
We're also going
to introduce you
to some of the people who are
using Google Cloud to build
what's next for their business.
And importantly,
we'll also tell you
how you can use Google Cloud
today for the workloads
that you're currently
operating, as well.
So in the next five
years, we're going
to see more changes in computing
than we've seen in the last 20,
literally an explosion
of innovation.
This is an easy prediction.
You can see it in
biological systems
where a set of capabilities
gets established and starts
functioning well.
It provides a foundation
on which evolution
can accelerate rapidly.
We're entering a similar
period of innovation
in cloud computing today.
That's why it's so
important for all of us
to understand what's
next for cloud,
so we can take advantage of
it before our competitors do.
All of us in this
industry, at this point,
are under the same
pressure, and experiencing
the same challenge.
It's a challenge that
Google faces, itself,
which is how to create
better software, faster.
And the challenge
here is that what
constitutes better software,
user expectations of software,
continue to ratchet up.
Users expect software to
be constantly updated.
The apps on your phone today
are very different from the apps
that were on your phone just a
month ago, or even a week ago.
Users expect applications
to adapt to them
the first time they use them.
Great software
anticipates what we
want before we know
ourselves, and delights us.
Users are increasingly
deciding who
they'll do business with based
on how good their software is.
All this creates great
opportunities for all of us
in this room, really
exciting creative work.
But let's talk about some of
the work that's not so exciting.
Developers spend
way too much time
as operators, configuring
infrastructure,
making software work, rather
than making software great.
Our goal is to
make it easy to run
complex applications at global
scale, securely and reliably.
In order to do this,
we need to automate out
a lot of the management
and operation of software.
We call this approach
NoOps, and we're well
on the way to delivering
this with our products
like App Engine,
Kubernetes Google Container
Engine, and BigQuery.
Some of you may know one of our
largest customers, Snapchat.
Snapchat started on Google App
Engine as a student project.
Now, it has grown to
serve a global audience.
At times, it's constituted over
half of global SMS traffic.
It serves up to two
million queries per second,
and consumes network bandwidth
second only to YouTube.
And yet they've never
hired an operations team.
And they've been able
to scale to that level.
For these reasons, to support
those kind of workloads,
we've built a different
kind of cloud,
one that's based
on scalable data
and machine-learning
services to let you much more
easily create rich,
context-aware applications
with automated deployment and
management capabilities that
let you focus on
building great software
and shipping it multiple
times an hour if you want to.
To understand how this
cloud is different,
it's useful to look at
where a cloud came from.
Cloud really started
about 20 years ago
with the co-location model where
users could run their gear,
run their hardware in
someone else's building.
They could use a data center
without owning a data center.
This had profound implications.
It was a great
financial engineering
move for many companies.
What most of us
think of as cloud
today, these virtualized
data centers,
this virtualized
computing model,
shares a lot in common
with the co-location model.
The basic building blocks
of computing are the same.
You're still dealing with
CPUs, with storage arrays,
with load balancers.
But now, you're
dealing with them
as software-defined
virtual devices.
What was a purchase
order has become an API.
And this is had profound
implications for many people.
But it's still too
hard to orchestrate
all those components
to work together
in a dynamic
environment or at scale,
even when they're virtualized.
The second wave a cloud
model forces most developers
to spend most of their time
doing things other than making
great software.
Do we have enough servers?
Are they all patched?
Did we buy too much capacity?
Are we wasting money?
In this second wave of cloud,
this virtualize center model,
this never gets any easier.
In fact, if you're successful,
it gets a whole lot worse,
as you have to re-architect
your infrastructure
as your application grows.
But we will admit,
we used to run
this same kind of
infrastructure inside Google
until about 10 years ago.
Right?
And then we realized
we had to reinvent
how we did software
infrastructure to keep up
with our business ambitions.
So we rebuilt our
infrastructure based
on containers, the
technology that we invented.
We provided the Linux foundation
as now part of the core Linux
distribution, based on
containers rather than
computers.
Products like YouTube,
and Gmail, and Google Apps
serve millions of
users every second.
And their developers
are able to put code
into production
multiple times a day.
Right?
And those applications
are resilient and secure.
What makes this possible are
highly-automated orchestration
tools that let developers deploy
signed binaries into containers
without ever specifying
anything about the underlying
infrastructure.
Our developers never
spin up a server,
never configure a network,
never patch an operating system.
Instead, they focus on
building great software.
We call this the
third wave a cloud.
It's a combination of automated
services and scalable data.
Got one more.
So this is really what
some people are referring
to as serverless computing.
And it's something that
has been talked about quite
a bit in our industry lately.
But it's embedded deeply inside
Google and inside Google Cloud
Platform.
For the past decade, it's
how developers at Google
have worked, with products
like App Engine, which
lets you run a snippet of the
code, run a snippet of code
in the cloud and scale it up
or down, all the way to zero,
and only pay for it if
a user's accessing it;
products like
Container Engine that
lets you deploy code without
specifying what service it's
going to run on; or
products like BigQuery,
our NoOps data
warehouse appliance
that's low cost
and low operational
overhead allow companies
to deploy it very widely
across their
organizations to push
data-driven decision-making
across their company.
The code just executes.
And as an application developer,
you never manage servers,
and you never pay for any
servers you're not actually
using.
Isn't that what
cloud's supposed to be?
Flexible computing resources
available on demand.
And at Google, we have the
most integrated approach
to serverless architecture
across all of our products
so that you're able to integrate
it into the way you do things
without rewriting your code.
But if you're like most
people, like most companies,
you're also running
traditional virtual workloads.
You're not just doing new
application development,
new web scale computing.
And part of what
you need to do is
evaluate what's the right
cloud for your existing
virtual workloads.
It turns out that in order to
do a great job on third wave
cloud, you've also got to do a
great job on second wave cloud.
And so there are number
of capabilities in GCP
that make it an excellent
environment for existing
workloads, in almost every
case, the best environment
for existing workloads.
And what I want to do now
is go through a number
of those features
and show you how
Google Cloud Platform is
different for your existing
workloads.
One feature is custom
virtual machines.
This lets you design
a virtual machine
for your particular workload.
It's so you don't
routinely over-provision.
On average, this saves
our customers about 19%
when you look across all the
computing happening on GCP.
In some cases, it saved
customers a lot more.
Let's say, for example, you want
to have a virtual machine that
needs 18 cores.
But if you look at our
competitor's price list,
they have an offering at
16 cores and at 32 cores.
In Google Cloud Platform, just
design a machine with 18 cores.
Build the virtual
machine shape that you
need for your workload.
It's really simple.
Use only what you need.
Pay only for what you use.
This is very different
from other cloud providers.
If you're running
Hadoop today, if you're
doing big data in the cloud, we
have a product called DataProc.
It's a managed Hadoop
and SPARC distribution.
You can spin up a
cluster in 90 seconds.
Spin it down.
Don't pay for it if
you're not using it.
Because it's so dynamic, and
we can so quickly bring it up,
you don't have to
leave it running.
You can run it when you need
it, and take it down when you
don't.
This is unlike what
our competitors
do where because it takes so
long to bring up the cluster,
the customers tend to leave
it running, and paying
for it while it runs.
Again, use only what you need.
Pay only for what you use.
Archival storage
has traditionally
meant trading speed for cost.
Right?
So you can either
get cheap storage
and wait for hours to
get your data back,
or you can pay for
performance storage
and have access to your
data in milliseconds.
What we've done is combine
these two with an offering
called Nearline that gives
you millisecond access to data
for pennies a gigabyte,
combining the speed of disk
with the price of tape.
VM startup times, VM startup
times on Google Cloud Platform
are just about 30 seconds now.
We continue to improve
performance as we go along.
This means that on
Google Cloud Platform,
you can start up
100 virtual machines
in the time it takes to
start one virtual machine
on our competitor's cloud.
It's 100 to 1.
That's two orders of magnitude.
So I just want to
give you an example,
so you can really
understand this difference.
Today, I went for a
run before this event.
I was running around
Roppongi Hills.
I was running about six miles
an hour, so I run pretty slow.
When I fly back
to San Francisco,
the plane that I fly on will
go almost 600 miles an hour.
That's two orders of
magnitude difference.
The difference between
a jog and a jet plane,
that's the difference
between Google Cloud
Platform and our competitors.
High-performance virtual
machine networking,
we deliver 16 gigabits
per second to almost all
the virtual machines
in our rate card.
Only this very smallest, the
very entry level offering,
has a lower bandwidth
network provisioning
to that virtual machine.
What this means is
your virtual machines
are never starved for data.
And you don't have to provision
the most expensive machine
types in our rate card in order
to do data-intensive tasks.
Right?
For Google Cloud, we believe
that all your virtual machines
should have access
to all the data they
need to do their work.
No other cloud offers
such high performance
across all these instance types.
And on GCP, it's a standard
feature at no extra cost.
As Rick said, we
operate a global network
with 77 points of
presence across the world.
This means that you can
peer with our network
and get access to your
customers worldwide.
You can see we have a number of
points of presence around Asia.
What's more, our
networking functions
are delivered as
managed services.
They're not hardware
virtual appliances
that you have to configure, just
managed services that you call.
A great example of this is
our global load balancer.
Right?
Instead of having essentially
virtual appliances
that you have to
configure and synchronize
DNS settings across
availability zones,
our global load balancer is
just a service that you call.
It's one URL for
your application,
and we load balance across
the regions you specify.
Now, what's more,
it scales from 0
to 1 million queries per
second in less than a second.
You don't have to
call us up beforehand
and let us know that you're
about to have some load.
The service just
responds to the load
as it comes in, very,
very different from what
our competitors offer.
So pricing, pricing is still
very, very important for cloud,
particularly if you're
running large scale workloads,
or you're making a large
commitment to cloud computing.
The Google Cloud
Platform, we offer,
in total, a discount
of up to 59%,
relative to our competitors.
I just want to break
that down for you.
The custom virtual
machines that I
talked about a few minutes ago,
that's 19% savings right there.
And then our rate card, our
standard list price rate card,
we're significantly
cheaper than competitors
because the scale
we're operating at.
We have purchasing power,
and we have efficiencies,
just because we're twice
as big as they are.
And then there's
a set of features
we call customer-friendly
pricing where we've
adapted our business models to
match the way customers consume
cloud computing.
For example, we're the
only cloud provider
that offers per-minute billing.
Everyone else
bills you per hour.
We're also the
only cloud provider
that offers a
sustained use discount.
Sustained use discounts
means you automatically
get a discount the more
you use the platform.
We also offer preemptible
virtual machines, which
are ideal for bursty workloads.
Those offer a 70%
discount if we can
interrupt the virtual
machine when we need it.
So what's really important about
all these discounts is they
all work together automatically.
You don't have to do
some contract with us.
some fancy scripting
to use different
aspects of our platform.
The price savings
happen automatically.
And this means that
we're just much, much
easier to do business with.
A company called Quizlet wrote
a comparison of Amazon Web
Services and Google Cloud
Platform last March,
and it's very detailed
across a number of subjects.
But one of the things they
talk about is pricing.
Google Cloud Platform
pricing is much friendlier,
and you're likely to
save a lot of money
with Google Cloud Platform.
So how does this work?
How can you get started
with Google Cloud Platform?
How is it really different?
To tell you more
about this, I am
delighted to be able to
introduce my friend, my sensei,
Miles Ward, the Head of--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--oop.
The Head of Solution
Architecture
of the Google Cloud Platform.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
MILES WARD: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
Miles Ward-san.
MILES WARD THROUGH
INTERPRETER: I am Miles Ward.
I'm quite big geek, a
little bit weird geek.
The Japanese as a language
is really, really difficult.
MILES WARD: It's because
I'm not very good.
Thank you for
coming to our event
and participating with
us in what we think
will be an incredible
first step, or maybe
your second and third
steps, into cloud.
My name's Miles.
And what I'm going to do
today is to try and show you
how Google has built all of
these differentiated features.
And I'm going to demonstrate
three different ways
that you can use
those tools to make
a big impact in your business.
If you look at the
constellation of services,
all the different
pieces that we've
built, from tools of every
different size and shape,
it can look very
complicated when you
look at Google Cloud Platform.
We have a lot to offer.
But in reality, if
you break this down
into something that's
a little simpler,
we've built three basic tiers of
service, first, infrastructure
and operations tools that
allow you to have access
to the same basic resources
that Google uses to build
its incredible services.
Above that, if you're
building new applications,
or hosting applications
where you control the code,
our application deployment
and development environment
is, bar none, the easiest,
simplest, fastest way
to get your code into
the hands of customers.
And our data environment,
how many folks
have heard of Google's
mission statement
where we organize and make
useful the world's information?
It turns out that's something
we have a lot of tools for.
And we're really excited to
share those tools with you
so that you can
organize and make
useful the data that's
critical to your businesses
and your customers.
So if you think about each
of these different tools,
they all stand on
top of each other.
And the innovations that
we've made all the way down
at the pavement, at the
basic foundational components
of our infrastructure,
have a huge positive effect
on every one of the
layers further and further
up the stack.
That kind of investment in
innovation over the last 17
years of our business has meant
that our data centers are just
a little weird.
They're very different
than other environments.
And I want to explain
how that works.
It really starts with power.
In the average data center,
about 40% of the power consumed
is used for something other
than actually computing.
It's used for cooling,
or power distribution,
or its losses in transformation.
It's because these systems are
designed in older generation
technologies.
Google's data centers are
some of the most efficient
in the world.
We use less than 10% of
our power for something
other than computing.
And overall, we use
less power as a total.
That means we get almost 200%
more processing power out
of the same electricity than
we did just five years ago.
Now, when we use less
power, we spend less money.
And that means our systems cost
less, which is good for you.
But it also is
good for the world.
Google is taking very
seriously our commitment
to the environment.
We're the number one
buyer in the United States
of renewal energy, number
one in green energy.
We're buying 2 gigawatts
of energy a year.
For those who are
counting, that's
roughly 2 time-traveling
DeLoreans,
which is just a weird
combination for us to measure.
We've been carbon
neutral since 2007.
And 100% of our power
usage is carbon offset.
We consider this a core
differentiation of the way
that our platforms are
a steward of the earth.
When you run on GCP, you
inherit that benefit.
You don't pay for
excessive overhead.
You don't pay for the
inefficient use of power.
And we think that kind
of efficient application
of infrastructure across all
of the layers of our stack
make your systems better,
make your systems faster.
It's not just about
building great data centers
from an efficiency standpoint.
It doesn't matter if they're
cheap if they aren't secure.
And we've focused an
embedded security technology
at the very foundation
of our businesses
because security
is core to Google,
and GCP is a part of Google.
We've invested at every layer
of our infrastructure stack.
We have differentiations
at the physical layout.
We have our own kinds
of security there.
We have our own networking.
We have our own
computer designs.
facility designs.
We have our own
software controls.
software deployment.
Each of these different layers
is secured by Google engineers
to ensure that your systems
are safe, that your customers'
data is safe.
That's done through automation,
through software, not
just about applying
enough people
to double check every
line and make sure
that things are working, but
to ensure that automatically,
your infrastructure
is protected.
If it's not automatic, it's
a bug, and we have to fix it.
So we've made that
investment over time,
and we'll continue to
grow that investment.
Some of that has paid
dividends in new inventions.
We're the ones who invented
elliptic curve cryptography.
We've added second-factor
authentication
to all of our services, so
you can use a hardware key
to ensure that you
are the only one who
will have access to your tools.
And all of those
innovations, and many more,
including encryption in
transit and at rest for all GCP
services, are built
by a team, not
of 500 security guards, or 500
security auditors, or analysts,
but 500 security engineers,
software developers
building the cutting edge of
security technology today.
These are the engineers
who discovered Heartbleed,
who discovered Rowhammer.
And recognize, when they find
it in our infrastructure,
we fix it here first and
then release that innovation
and technology to the wild.
So your systems can take
advantage of that cutting edge
security by being built
on Google Cloud Platform.
And we do all of that oriented,
as our whole businesses
is, around speed.
We're the ones who said
performance is a feature.
And so we're not willing
to compromise speed
and performance for security.
We think you can
get both together.
It's not, also, about
actually being secure.
We need to prove that
we're secure to others.
We need to earn your trust
by earning the certifications
and credentials that show
the world that we absolutely
know what we're doing
around security.
So we're PCI compliant.
You can store credit
card data with us.
We're HIPAA compliant.
You can build health
care systems on us.
We follow the full ISO 27000.
In fact, many of
these standards,
we're on the defining body for.
We help the industry
as it writes
new standards to
establish the security
credentials that all customers
and all public providers
adhere to.
And it's that
constant investment
in a never-ending
effort to secure
our systems that differentiates
GCP from a security standpoint.
But you don't have to
take my word for it.
You can actually see one.
Who wants to see a data center?
They are awesome.
They are really
cool looking inside.
I promise.
If you go into our
playground, you
can use Google Cardboard
to take a 360 degree
tour of the data center.
You can see our racks,
and our switches,
and our networking, and
our power distribution.
It's really incredible stuff.
But you'll notice-- look
around-- there will always
be a security guard in view
because we take security, even
in our demos, very,
very seriously.
So security is important.
We think that's sort
of a critical step.
But we also know that what
you need from your systems
is security, and by
way of availability.
You need to feel secure that
they're going to keep running.
And we've done a lot of
innovation in this area.
So live migration is
a feature unique to us
among other hyperscale clouds.
We're the only
providers that have it.
What it allows us to do is to
take a running virtual machine,
even a virtual machine with
terabytes of local solid state
disk, doing hundreds of
thousands of operations
a second to storage, and
move that virtual machine
to other hosts without
skipping a beat.
So that means if we're
blowing network alarms,
or there's a problem
with the storage device,
or we want to update
the software, patch it
for security, or we
want to reshuffle
the layout of infrastructure
to make efficient
the usage of our
resources, live migration
allows us to do that
transparently with no downtime.
You get no email from
us that says, hold on.
I please need you to
restart your computers.
That is yesterday's cloud.
We won't make you do that.
That allows our services to
not only offer this to you,
but recognize all
of the tools we've
built above that infrastructure
inherit that ability.
They are all more available.
Our databases, and our
development environments,
and our processing
infrastructure, they
all use this capability.
So your tools can be more highly
available, and so are ours.
And in order to
have that work, it
has to stand on top of a totally
unique network infrastructure.
So we've built a global
software-defined network.
You can read about this stuff.
It's in an Andromeda
white paper.
It's really an incredible
system for orchestrating
the movement of data, not
just inside of our facilities,
but across the world.
In many ways, this allows us
to treat all of our regions
as a single global
computer, very
different than a
collection of resources
you have to figure out
how to connect together.
And we're growing
that cloud over time.
So you've already
heard that we're
very excited to add a
region here in Tokyo.
I'm excited.
I hope you're excited.
It's going to be an
incredible facility.
But we'll be adding even
more, in fact, 10 more data
centers over the next year, new
facilities that allow not only
for you to get better
performance for customers
locally, but to take
your products to market
around the world.
So those additions of new
facilities over time will make
it so that this system is ready
to serve today's applications
and tomorrow's.
So we know that that
connectivity between facilities
is a core part of our
security story, right?
This is a global private
Google-owned network.
This is entirely our
fiber that allows
us to control not only
access to that network,
but the routing and performance
of packet transmissions
across it.
That ensures that your
applications, even if they're
located far, far away
from where your users are,
deliver the very best
performance possible.
To give you some idea of
the scale of what we're
talking about, some kind of
view to just how big this is,
we're looking at a network
today that's over a petabyte
a second of
bisectional bandwidth.
For context, that's four
times the size of this thing
you may have heard of
called the internet.
So it's [JAPANESE], right?
So--
MILES WARD THROUGH
INTERPRETER: It's so big.
MILES WARD: --when you see these
systems working in concert,
it allows customers to build
incredible applications.
I have an example of just
that kind of customer
that I'd love you to
take a look at now.
Please roll the video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
KENJI SHIOIRI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
So now, I would
like to introduce
our marvelous customer.
From CyberAgent, Executive
Director Mr. Nagase
is on the stage with me.
And looking at that VTR,
many of the participants
are knowing this service.
But could you please
talk about your service
and what kind of
business you are running?
MR. NAGASE THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Yes, it
was a very punchy video.
But CyberAgent and TV Asahi
are cooperating internet TV
channel.
So news, or
animation, or sports,
there are 30 channels
available, 24 by 7 for free.
So Abema TV is the
name of the service.
And I like fishing,
and I'm always
watching fishing channel.
And Abema TV is putting
a very high standard
on the TV quality.
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
And the actual users, now,
how many users do you have?
MR. NAGASE THROUGH INTERPRETER:
We started this in April,
and four months or
so, have passed.
And 7 million downloads
or more we had.
And we have several
applications,
but the growth of
this service is
unprecedented in our company.
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
So 7 million downloads,
that's great, and TV quality
you are adhering to.
So to meet that expectations,
so Google Platform, or Google
Container Engine,
or micro-services,
you have adopted so many
innovative technologies
and services.
And what's the reason why
you selected Google services?
MR. NAGASE THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Over the internet,
if you want to show TV programs,
then quality is very important.
So we put high
expectation on SLA.
And we analyzed the
failure logs in the past.
And we found that GCP
services and Google services
were very stable, based
upon our analysis.
And that's why we
selected your services.
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
So what are you expecting
of GCP toward the future?
MR. NAGASE THROUGH
INTERPRETER: So my expectation
is on the Tokyo region, latency
will become even smaller.
And real-time image distribution
or video distribution
becomes possible.
So we are waiting for
Tokyo region opening.
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
I think the many of you are
also waiting for that too.
So more technical
details of Abema TV
will be presented
in the lunch time.
So in the Container
session, more details
will be given on Abema TV.
Thank you very much, Mr. Nagase.
MR. NAGASE THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MILES WARD: [INAUDIBLE]
It's exciting, isn't it,
watching somebody actually
build and deploy a system
following our best practices,
right, following the
way that we describe,
and we've seen proved true
to be a super efficient way
to serve users?
When we talk to customers,
we're hearing about efficiency.
We hear a lot of questions
about a pragmatic approach,
an approach where, as a user,
you want all of the options
to be available, not just
one piece of software,
or one cloud, but all
of the systems that
are valuable to you.
And Google, maybe different
than some of our competitors,
is comfortable with that.
You should have all of
the options that you want.
You should be able to run
any kind of system any place.
And we've started to
make real investments
in making that kind of
multi-cloud, multi-environment
infrastructure something
that's not just possible,
but actually pretty easy.
We're making those investments
across different layers
of our stack.
And I actually
want to demonstrate
some of these tools for you.
So the first of those is an
innovation called Stackdriver.
Stackdriver allows you to
monitor and meter, build alarms
and alerts, across
infrastructure built
not only on Google Cloud
Platform, but also,
on AWS and other environments.
So that means you can
manage and observe
your infrastructure
from a single view,
no matter where it runs.
So I want to demonstrate
this for you.
Or actually, Nobu
from our team--
everybody give him a big
hand-- he's going to do
a demonstration--
[APPLAUSE]
--of Stackdriver
together with me.
And we'll take a look
through just how this
can change the way
that you manage
the software for your business.
So if we can switch to
the demo screen, please.
So this is the user
interface for Stackdriver.
Stackdriver, if you
can see, is actually
showing us accounts from
Google Cloud Platform,
but also, registered
AWS accounts.
I have access to both systems
from one user interface.
And we've actually
built an application,
which is distributed across
those two environments.
We'll log in and take
a look at the metrics
for that application, so you
can see exactly what Stackdriver
is measuring.
If you log into that system,
what you'll first see
is that Apache is serving web
traffic from AWS, and also,
a little from GCP, but most
of it on the Amazon side.
We're able to look at how many
individual flags were called,
what's the total request volume
against the load balancer.
He's here navigating
in to look at
more specifically at what's
happening on Amazon's load
balancer.
So you can really unpack
infrastructure systems running
on our side and on others.
So here, here's seeing a
little spike in latency.
Who knows what's
wrong with the ELB.
I don't know.
That's Amazon's problem.
Our systems are running
fairly stably though.
Let's go take a look at NGINX.
That's running, balancing
for our infrastructure.
As you move through
this system, you'll
be able to see exactly the
latency between our endpoints,
how many connections are
open at a given time,
and what's the health of
the individual resources
that you're consuming, how many
waiting connections you have.
All those measures allow you
to diagnose and understand
exactly what's happening
in your infrastructure.
So we're also going to take
a look at the front end
dashboard, so we can really
view what's happening
as exposed to our customers.
And you'll see requests
against the Apache cluster
that's running on Amazon,
total requests against the load
balancer, now, what's
happening from CPU capacity,
and other pieces.
But we're also going to want
to be able to see changes
as they happen, right?
So we're going to make
an adjustment in the way
that our system is managed.
We're actually going to slide
traffic from the Amazon side
over to the side
that's running on GCP.
And that way we can watch
not only all the measures
adjust as these
systems run through
and react to the new data
coming from our front ends,
but we can also see
the individual log
messages that are coming off.
This is an integrated
part of the system.
So rather than hunting around
for some different tool,
you can individually
query and evaluate
that real live, real-time
incoming log messages
from your user front end.
So you can see
individual records
are coming in now as we watch.
And then if we come back to
the primary Stackdriver system,
you'll be able to observe
the change in traffic
on our infrastructure.
Right?
So slowly the AWS
Apache requests,
they will trail off over time.
And then the new
requests coming into GCP
will trend up over time.
So that environment,
that Stackdriver system,
lets you get one view to observe
the behavior of a system that
spans multiple clouds.
Everybody give Nobu a
big round of applause.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate the demonstration.
Good job.
[APPLAUSE]
Go back to slides.
So if that's a system for
monitoring and managing
an application, no
matter how it's deployed,
that's maybe not a way to
solve the problem of deployment
itself.
So Google's made
a big investment
in container orchestration
technology, an open source
system called Kubernetes.
Kubernetes reflects
Google's expertise
with managing
containers where all
of the services that
we're looking at today
are running on
container technology.
Kubernetes allows you to build
your services the same way
to get to higher utilization,
higher redundancy,
higher efficiency
across, no matter
where you run that system.
I'm really excited today to
be able to demonstrate some
of the newest
features of Kubernetes
from version 1.3
that allow federation
across multiple clouds.
We'll demonstrate that today.
I'd like to introduce
Etsuji Nakai-san and Ian
Lewis to run that demo for us.
Everybody give them a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
ETSUJI NAKAI: Thank you, Miles.
And nice to meet you, everyone.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
ETSUJI NAKAI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
My name is Nakai at Google.
So I'd like to take
about 10 minutes.
So I work with Ian.
And I am going to introduce
Kubernetes in Japanese.
So Kubernetes' new
feature, I really
want you to feel
that new feature.
So that's the reason why I'd
like to show the demonstration.
To set up the context,
please bring your smartphones
or mobile terminals.
Please get your mobile devices,
and you boot up the browser
and type in the URL.
Or maybe you can use QR code,
and please access to this.
In, I think, last
week, Ian and myself
did not have any
good night's sleep.
This is a new
healing application.
I hope that you enjoy the
new healing application.
Yes.
Well, please click.
Please use the secure code
for access to this URL.
As Miles mentioned, let's
say if we use Stackdriver
in the multiple
cloud environment,
you can use one single tool
to manage the multiple cloud
environments.
If you use Kubernetes
to the multiple cloud,
you can transparently
deploy the application
into the multiple
cloud environments.
In this demonstration, we are
now having the GCP Asia region,
and also, we have the
competitor's cloud provider's
North American cloud.
So using Kubernetes, Kubernetes
is sold onto both environment.
We actually configured
the cluster.
1.3 cluster federation
as a new feature
can be used so that you
can use one console, trying
to transparently deal with the
multiple cloud environments.
So as you see, Ian is
actually sending the commands.
So one command, but
the command is going
into the two different clouds.
In case of GCP, the
back-end is eight containers
are used in the back-end.
You can actually see
it on that screen.
The North American,
the different cloud,
the application is not
up and running yet.
And on that chart is
the access from you.
So this venue and
satellite venue now
accommodates over 2,000 people.
But unfortunately,
it is not 2,000 yet.
But don't worry.
I am sure some of you
tweeted this application.
Right?
And I am sure throughout
Japan, all the users looking
at the tweet, I am sure that
they are now making access
to this application.
I think this could be
spur, but maybe joke aside.
But this as a specific
application region, the load
generator containers are
now booting up, 20 of them.
So load-bot, 20 load-bot.
It's about 20,000
QPS, 20,000 QPS.
Now it is handled in these
eight containers in back-end.
That's what we have.
And also, there is a
significant announcement.
As I said, the new healing
application, which I announced,
I hope that you are healed.
You are going through
the healing process.
I don't think this is
not a healing process,
but this is for the purpose
of the demonstration.
This is a setup application.
But, of course, Google members
or Googlers do not compromise.
Ian created the new version
of this application.
Ian told me that he
created the new version.
So the new version image
is already uploaded.
So you can actually see
the application version up.
All the setup is
declaration-based.
So in this one setup file, what
version, what configuration,
which cloud, it's all declared.
So as you see, the
application version.
So now, we change the
And the setup is going to
be reflected using command.
So all of this is automated.
I'm sure that you
heard the automation.
It's automatically upgrading
the application version.
And this upgrade is live.
So I don't want you to stop
accessing to this application,
but just keep
clicking the buttons.
And while you are accessing
to this application,
we are now upgrading
the application.
As you see, the blue
is getting smaller,
and the version 2, the green
container, is getting more.
So this is a rolling
update feature.
So by having this
feature, you don't
have to stop the
access from the users.
You can keep providing
the services.
But at the same time, you
can upgrade the version.
I am sure you are healed.
So this is Ian's new
version of the application.
So this new version
now attracts a lot
of users from overseas, now,
maybe from the North American
users, joke aside.
But what Ian is
doing is now looking
at the different cloud
provider's North American
region cluster.
As was before, we are not trying
to start the load-bot, load
generator.
So as you see, the applicator
is not up and running
in North America yet.
But because of this
cloud federation,
so network is also managed.
So the access from
the North America,
there is no application
in North America.
So that is going to be
transferred to Asia.
So as you see, the Google Cloud
access two times, 40,000 QPS.
But, of course, this is
not the ideal environment.
We want the access
from the North America
to receive those access
in North America.
That's the ideal.
So now, Ian is going to use
the exact same set of files,
and also, exactly same
configured application
to be loaded onto
the North America.
So because of the
federation feature,
so access from North
America is automatically
routed to the North
American cluster.
As you see on that screen,
the GCP access is coming down.
And the North American
provider's access
is getting more.
So total of 40 is now split
into 20,000 and 20,000.
So this is 1.3 cloud federation
to the multiple cloud.
You can actually deploy
application transparently,
and even include
in the network, you
can optimize the management
of those resources.
And Kubernetes is open source,
so you can use it anywhere.
Let's say, maybe
on-premise data center,
if you install Kubernetes onto
the on-premise data center,
then on-premise environment
and GCP involvement
can be federated as
one single environment.
It's also possible.
Kubernetes behind the
scene, what is going on?
If you are interested
technically
what's going on behind the
scene, in this afternoon
we have a breakout
session, and Ian
is going to make
the presentation
about the Kubernetes technology.
ETSUJI NAKAI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Then if
you are interested
in the technical
details of Kubernetes,
please go to that session too.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MILES WARD: So I was
watching on the clock.
I don't know if you
watched on the clock.
It took them six minutes
to launch an application,
update the application,
load test the application,
distribute the application
on more than one cloud.
I don't-- I don't think
that's even a record.
But I don't think
many of your systems
are ready to do that today.
That's a brand new feature.
It's a brand new capability
that could really change
the way that you use cloud.
We think, today, these
kinds of hybrid systems
that span multiple environments
are complex and siloed
and wrought with overhead
and operations risk.
And in the future, they'll
look like this, easy, easy.
We're excited about making that
as easy as possible for you.
That is ready today.
You can use that
exact technology
to power your systems today.
And that's the kind of advantage
that application developers are
seeing on top of our platform.
We have the same
challenge that you have.
Google wants to build
better software, faster,
just like you.
And these are the
tools that we've
used to be able to accelerate
our development process.
Whether your product or
business sells software,
or services, or
technology, at the heart,
all companies are becoming
software companies.
And it's accelerating a process
by which you can get value out
of software that we think
makes our platform very
differentiated.
Because we know
that for developers,
the reality is you
just want to code.
You don't want to have
to deal with setting up
machines, or configuring
networks, or making the VPN
work, or interconnecting to
different storage modalities.
You don't really want to have
to fuss with any of that.
We've made our systems for
this kind of management
more flexible over
time. [INAUDIBLE]
flex now allows all sorts
of different programming
languages, like even
Ruby now is available.
So you're seeing new richness
in our tools to enable all kinds
of different developers, even
.NET developers to be able
to run in this
kind of efficient,
scaled way without Ops.
And we think that that
makes not just a difference
in the performance
of your applications,
but it can change the culture
inside of your company.
When you go from being able to
do an experiment that you need
approval for because it's
going to take a month,
and you've got to buy computers,
and someone's got to set them
up, and you need to build
a coalition of four teams
to be able to get
something complete,
maybe you don't
innovate as often
as when a lone
developer can build
something amazing over lunch
and show the world what's new.
So we expect that what this
drives is a change in culture
that allows more people to spend
more time being more creative,
building new things and changing
the things that they don't like
faster than they've ever
changed them before.
In the place where you can see
some of the most incredible
change is in our data
and analytics services,
in our data tools that allow
companies not only take
and build new software,
but extend that software
with the power of data.
Software is the fuel.
Software is the engine
that data is the fuel for.
Right?
And we excel at processing
data, and transforming it,
and making it available
for you to use
in all of your applications.
And some of this has
started on us as research.
So we spent a lot
of time documenting
for the public's benefit
the innovation that
was happening inside Google.
We released white papers
like GFS and MapReduce.
I mean, MapReduce today
inspired the folks at Yahoo
to build Hadoop.
And Hadoop is now a
multi-billion dollar a year
ecosystem.
Someone at Google finally
got the smart idea,
maybe we should sell those.
So we did.
That's what Google's
Data Platform is,
is an externalization of
Google's infrastructure
systems, its data
processing systems,
so that you can use the same
tools that our engineers use.
Google built MapReduce.
Now, you can consume
that as Dataproc.
Google built Colossus.
Now, you can use
Google Cloud Storage.
Google built Stubby to
interconnect applications.
And now, you can use GRPC
to reduce the communications
overhead between the
layers of your app.
Google built Dremel.
You can use BigQuery, the most
incredible online application
processing environment
in the world.
Google built Bigtable.
Conveniently, that one's
still called Bigtable.
[LAUGHS]
And that system
allows you to build
in a way that's entirely open.
You talk to us using the
open source HBase API.
So each of these
inventions is not
just about better performance
or better availability.
It offers those, for sure.
But it's also about continuing
our investment and our promise
towards open source.
So if you think about
the work effort required,
lots of customers see these
kinds of big data systems,
distributed file systems, and
distributed NoSQL systems,
and think about the complexity
of managing and operating that.
A big differentiator
at Google is
these services are all managed.
We take the responsibility
for operations.
If you're short on DBA
resources, if you have no DBA,
it's no big deal.
You can still consume from
us and scale your business
without all of the operational
requirement of running
your stateful services.
I'm pretty excited.
I think there are a lot
of businesses that are
taking great advantage of this.
But one example customer
I want to introduce to you
the stage, Maeda-san from
Recruit and K.J. Shioiri.
Please give them a
big round of applause.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
ENJI SHIOIRI THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Thank you.
So I'd like to introduce one
more great customer of ours,
from Recruit Technology, the
Managing Director, Mr. Maeda.
Mr. Maeda, Miles,
just before this, I
think he went through
the data analytics,
and he introduced
different technologies.
Well, maybe first of all, you
can talk about what you do
and what kind of services
you offer to the customer.
So would you please
talk about that?
KOICHIRO MAEDA
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Yes, simply stated,
we are underneath
of the Recruit Group.
We are the expert
in the technologies.
As you see, we have quite a wide
variety of different services
offered by Recruit.
Maybe the carrier jobs,
automobile, and restaurants,
and beauty salon, and also,
they are getting married.
However, we have a
lot of data generated
from different services.
How could we best
leverage those data,
trying to offer the better
services to the customers?
And how can we
delight the customers?
So using the expert
technologies,
we are the ones which
develops the solutions.
ENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Well, I understand that
you are dealing with quite
a massive volume of data.
As Miles mentioned, we
offer different solutions.
Well, what solutions of Google
do you use in your businesses?
KOICHIRO MAEDA THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Well, maybe I'd
like to introduce two use cases.
One is this one.
Using App Engine, we
manage BigData API.
As you see it, Art,
this is our internal,
based upon Machine
Learning, this
is a BigData solution offered
to our internal customers.
They are different logos.
Well, each one is used for
text analysis, or maybe
image analysis.
So using Machine Learning,
and we publicize with API,
and we use these solutions
for the internal users.
Each one is a different service.
But we integrate or
consolidate those.
And that front end API
is using App Engine.
So maybe we can offer
the account, or maybe
certification.
Well, the other thing
which I want to introduce
is using BigQuery.
We offer data
warehouse on BigQuery.
We have acquired a
different business lines,
or LLPs within Recruit Group.
And we need to go through
the different analytics
for each LLP.
So depending on the
purpose of that LLP,
we have to create a data mart
specific to that business.
So we have different
data warehouses.
And we implemented
BigQuery, consolidate
with be BI Tool, and trying
to enhance our analytics
capabilities.
ENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Well, I think Google
Cloud Platform, usually,
you are reminded
with the App Engine.
That's our first service.
But now, we have a lot
of container technology
throughout the industry.
So Google App Engine customers
are now getting more and more.
That's the trend.
And also, regarding
the BigQuery,
you have quite a huge
volume of the data.
Well, I think we have a
different analytics approaches.
But using Google technologies
used for your analytics,
do you see any change
in terms of how you
approach the analytics itself?
KOICHIRO MAEDA THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Well, maybe I
can say that.
As was mentioned before,
we have different APIs,
and we use like NoOps.
Well, what kind of management we
have in the volume or the usage
is getting more and more.
So what should we do
with our front end API?
And we think NoOps as a concept
really matches our environment.
So by connecting to
BigQuery directly,
we can immediately
do the analytics.
How API is being utilized
is also analyzed.
So depending on the results,
we could evolve that API.
So it's not just a
simple analytics.
But it is useful to the new
service development, yes.
And also, when it comes
to the data warehouse,
for each section, we
have data warehouse.
So at the beginning, we
have two major issues.
One is how much more
data to be generated.
So the one issue is
a scalability issue.
The other is, I said,
integrated with BI Tool.
The number of the user
is also increasing.
Maybe at the beginning,
few power users.
But eventually, we have
more and more users.
So how many concurrent users
do we have to consider?
That's a second issue.
BigQuery solved those problems.
ENJI SHIOIRI THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Well,
thank you very much.
And BigQuery, Google itself.
So Dremel, it's called Dremel.
And we also have a
huge volume of data.
And Google also used this
tool for our own purpose
in terms of the analytics.
Well, Google Platform is
also is used by Recruit.
Well, other than Google
Platform, any other Google
tools you are using
other than GCP?
KOICHIRO MAEDA
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Well, Apps, so for the company
like Recruit, I think security
and management are really,
really important in using GCP.
So in order to really have
a good account management,
I think it's really important
to have the account management.
ENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
So maybe from the
security perspective,
you are also using
GCP plus App Engine.
KOICHIRO MAEDA THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Yes.
ENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Well, maybe into the future,
what kind of expectation
do you have to us in the future?
KOICHIRO MAEDA THROUGH
INTERPRETER: OK, as I said,
security is really a
key for any companies
to be able to use GCP.
In many use cases, I
think security is a key.
I'm really glad to hear that
you make a great investment
onto security.
But I hope that you
keep doing that.
Well, the next expectation
is that because we
are doing BigData,
Big Data really
has a great
chemistry with cloud.
So maybe you are always a
front runner in this area.
So I hope that maybe you could
also leverage Machine Learning,
and also, you could leverage
your GCP itself so that we,
also, can enjoy the
benefit of using GCP.
ENJI SHIOIRI THROUGH
INTERPRETER: So BigQuery,
and also data
analytics, also offered
in the breakout
sessions for details.
And so if you are
interested, please
come to those sessions
in the afternoon today.
KOICHIRO MAEDA
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MILES WARD: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
Good job.
How exciting is that, watching
those data tools work together
to build a platform that's
creating so much value?
I think we should look
as closely as we can
at that data platform.
I want to look very deeply
at exactly how it works.
So I brought to the
stage [INAUDIBLE].
Everybody give him a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to demonstrate
the end-to-end Google Cloud
Platform for data processing.
Does that sound good?
So we worked together with
one of our favorite customers,
Spotify.
Spotify builds a music
streaming service for the world.
And they have a very
large infrastructure
deployed on top of GCP.
That infrastructure
serves millions
of end users' mobile phones
as they stream data all
around the world.
It turns out that system creates
an incredible amount of data.
That's a rich resource for them
to understand customers, be
able to offer them new
services and products.
So we worked together with them
to sanitize a set of that data.
So from Spotify to
test-ify because they
think of their data
as very sensitive,
just like they should,
and we want to make sure
that we respect user privacy.
So that test data
set is not just
a static file, a flat
file of information.
It's actually a running
stream, which produces, just
like their real application,
over 100,000 requests
per second.
So you can see here-- this
is again from Stackdriver--
where we're publishing
this huge rate of data
into our active systems.
So Stackdriver allows you
to monitor and observe
that ingestion, but
where is that data going?
Once we have access
to a source of data,
how do we move it
into an environment
where we can make it useful
and earn value from it?
So the next step
is to use a product
from us called Cloud Data Flow.
You can see in this user
interface we're consuming data,
but we're also orchestrating
its distribution
across not only BigQuery,
our query environment,
but also, directly into GCS
for archival or later storage.
And then we can even write
externally to some other HDFS.
You saw the model from Recruit.
They run lots of
data warehouses.
There's no reason
that you shouldn't
have the data in exactly
the format that you need.
And Data Flow is not
only this user interface,
but an execution environment,
an automatically scalable,
distributed cluster
of computers doing
the work of
transforming that data
and loading it into
your system of choice.
It does that using the ParDo,
or parallel execution model that
makes it super, super
easy to write that code.
If you've ever done this kind
of work in SPARC or in Presto,
you're looking at
this much code.
And if you do it in a
ParDo, in Data Flow,
it's about this much code.
I promise.
So once you've transformed
and loaded that data
into the different environments
where you want to access it,
first thing you're probably
going to want to do
is write some queries,
maybe totally ad hoc queries
that you've never tried before.
In this, what we would want
to do is say, for example,
let's just figure out
who the most frequently
played artist is.
Maybe that's who the best
musician in the world is.
This query will run across
hundreds of millions of rows
of data on our side,
automatically counting up which
plays lasted full length,
which individual artists
were played most frequently.
So we've already processed
gigabytes of totally
unpreprocessed, unindexed data.
And we found out that,
ooh, bummer, Justin Bieber
is the best artist.
No, I think that's
a terrible result.
I don't think Justin
Bieber is the best.
I'm sure that something
has gone terribly wrong,
and I need to collaborate
with data scientists
to find a much better
answer than this answer.
So I will use Cloud Data Lab.
That's an environment for
writing together, just like you
write in a Google doc together.
Only in this, you
can write Python.
So this is built on top of the
IPython or Jupyter Notebook
format where not
only can you keep
notes, and data,
and examples-- you
could tie-in to outside data
resources like BigQuery--
but you can also write code
and execute that code directly
from this interface.
So as a collaborative
researcher together with a team,
you can start to look
at different models,
like the Pandas Library
for understanding data.
You can do counts
and trajectories.
You can even see visualizations
for that data here.
We've looked at a
model where we're
looking at the number
of full-length playbacks
and the diversity of those
using a thing called the Pandas
Waiting Library.
If you scroll a little
further down on this
what you'll be able to
see is that there's maybe
a slightly different outcome
than just having only Justin
Bieber be the best.
And turns out that
not Dusty Springfield,
because this is ordered
inverse, the best artist
is actually Nirvana,
which I like very much.
I'm from Seattle.
It even smells a little
like teen spirit in here.
It's good.
Nirvana is a much better
answer than Justin Bieber,
in my humble opinion.
So this kind of
information I would
want to share with my boss.
All right. once you've
got a clear answer,
you're going to want to
package it up and publish it,
maybe not just to your
internal stakeholders,
but to the rest of the world.
This is a tool from us
called Cloud Data Studio.
It's a part of the
data analytics platform
from Google Cloud Platform.
And it allows you to not only
do simple charts, and graphs,
and pie, and
distributions of data,
but it's a real
interactive user interface
for navigating through
a preparation of data
that you can build.
So that means you'd be
able to see which artists
are popular at what times.
Maybe they're popular
in different regions
or geographies around the world.
That kind of view allows
executives to quickly
take results from the
research that you've built.
So think about that.
In just the span of the
last 2 and 1/2 minutes,
we've gone from ingesting
a huge amount of data.
Most businesses don't have
100,000 requests a second
for their front ends.
Ingestion, distribution,
and orchestration, ad hoc
and program querying,
collaboration
around data science,
and publication
all on Google Tools, all
managed by us, no operations
overhead, no DBA, no big deal,
that's a very different data
environment than the rest of
the world experiences today.
And I hope that you come
with us to experience
just this environment.
Everybody give [INAUDIBLE]
a really big hand.
Great job.
[APPLAUSE]
Back to slides.
So today, a lot of the time--
I mean, I built a startup.
It took us a month and a
half to turn on Hadoop.
That's a little different
than [POP] point
and click and start doing
analysis in BigQuery.
Right?
So today, you babysit
infrastructure.
You coddle systems.
You work overtime to make
sure that they're available.
And we think next, instead,
you'll just get insights.
You just get answers.
You'll get the data that you
need to make better business
decisions, and you'll
get that data now,
instead of waiting for
hours for a process
to run because you don't
have enough compute capacity.
We have enough compute capacity.
I promise.
So this is really just
the tip of the iceberg
of getting value out of the
data that you've collected.
So we worked very hard
over the last several years
in making incredible
investments in Machine Learning,
deep learning, and
convolutional neural networks.
So even just four
years ago in 2012,
you're looking at bare
academic experimentation
between a couple
of teams as they
start to look at how
Machine Learning might
impact the future of
the Google business.
And now, today, over 1,500
distinct software projects
inside Google are using
model definition files,
have Machine Learning as a
component of their production
operation.
Right?
So there's almost
no Google service
that isn't today powered in
some way by Machine Learning.
Think about that.
That's a huge change in
a short period of time.
I mean, for example,
in search, everybody's
used Google Search
before, I suspect.
It is now the third signal.
The third most important
signal in search
comes from a Machine
Learning model about what's
likely to be relevant to you.
So we know that this is going
to make an enormous impact
in every business across all
of the different categories
of effort as you try to
understand and digest data.
We know.
We're sure.
So we've taken some big steps
to bring this power to you,
because we think it's
really what's next.
So first, we've
pre-baked and built
our own ready-to-use
Machine Learning models.
So you need no Machine Learning
expertise, no crazy PhD data
scientists.
You just start
hooking to our APIs.
You want to be able
to translate text,
we have the translate API.
You want to understand
what's available in pictures,
you use the Vision API.
You want to be able to
process the things that I
say into text, that's
the Speech API.
You want to be able to
understand the information
inside of that text.
That's the Natural
Language Processing API.
Each of these tools, I mean,
imagine the combination of them
in concert.
Take Google Photos.
If I pull my phone
out and I say--
this will probably mess up
a lot of people's phones.
I say, OK, Google, find me
pictures of kids in a boat.
I hear phones
doing it right now.
[LAUGHS]
Right?
Think about what happens.
I said the word
"kids in a boat."
It has to can use the Speech
API to convert that to text,
extract that kids and
boats are real things,
identify those things in
all of my tens of thousands
of pictures, and then retrieve
those pictures to show me.
It can do all of that in
hundreds of milliseconds.
In production, at scale,
for billions of users,
Google is doing this today.
And your businesses all already
have access to these APIs.
You can build that magic
into your applications
without having to understand
all of the complexity
of the foundational Machine
Learning technology.
You just get to use.
But we know that's actually
just the first step.
The first step will be
applying these technologies
and new models as we come
up with them over time.
We're actually building
more as we speak.
We expect that this kind of
rich data where you get access
to what is inside of the
analog information you have,
right, a picture is
just a series of pixels
until you can say these are--
oh, there's pictures of cats.
Or there's people.
Or that's where faces are.
Or that's the logo
of my company.
Or that person's naked.
Or all these kind of
information that you
can get out of the data
that you already have.
So as we add this
kind of richness
to even more types
of data, we think
you'll be able to get
quite a bit of value.
But we also think it will
allow you to be very creative.
We're watching incredible
experimentation, people
building art, and
music, and poetry
on top of Machine Learning.
It's really a new Wild West of
innovative and creative ideas.
And so we know you'll want
to build your own models.
And Google has some very
real innovation here, too.
Right?
We're not just interested
in Machine Learning
kind of, sort of.
We know that this is a huge part
of our business going forward.
So we don't run Machine Learning
models on our computers,
because that's 2012.
We don't even run it on
GPUs because that's 2014.
GPUs are nice, but we've
built our own custom
ASICs, our own hardware,
just for Machine Learning
processing.
It's called a Tensor
Processing Unit.
It's a part that
no one else has.
We built them from
scratch for ourselves.
And they are in
production today.
We have custom silicon
just for doing this work.
And to get access to that
infrastructure horsepower,
we've started to build
a Machine Learning API,
a system that will take the open
source system that we built,
called TensorFlow -- that's
the number one machine learning
library in the
world, by the way--
take TensorFlow code
that you build anywhere.
You build on your Raspberry Pi.
You build on your phone.
You build on your laptop.
You build on somebody
else's cloud.
You build on our cloud.
And if you want to
run that in production
at scale for billions
of users, you
can use the Machine
Learning API to access
Google's unique hardware
for accelerated execution
and simplified development.
That's in alpha today.
We'll be moving
to beta very soon.
We know that's
exciting technology
for the folks in the audience.
And we're excited to
get you access to it.
But what you'll
learn right away is
as you try to build
your own models,
you need the same
thing that Google
needed to build
what we've built.
You're going to need a
whole mountain of data.
I mean, a double mountain.
Petabytes is a good start.
And you're going to need
some kind of process
for shuffling that data
and making it organized
and clean in a way that it
can be used to train systems.
And you're probably going want
to collaborate with your peers
as you evaluate that data.
Remember that whole list
of tools we used before?
It's the same stuff.
We've already built
a platform designed
to make data learnable.
And that's why we
think we're the best
place to start your
experimentation and innovation
around Machine Learning.
So today, you probably
spend a lot of your focus
on storing, and backing
up, and maybe occasionally,
analyzing your data.
What w think what
will happen next
is you'll be able to
liberate the value
inside of the information
you already have,
and to collaborate together
with your peers and the broader
community around the data
that surrounds us all.
It's really an incredible
time that's coming.
And this is not just
because it's fun,
or that it's super fascinating.
I think it's very interesting.
But it's also going to
make people a lot of money.
So this is our
Chairman Eric Schmidt.
He said that the next five big
IPOs will come from businesses
that have innovated on top of
Machine Learning technology,
just the same way as the
last round of large IPOs
have come out of apps
and mobile technology.
We really think it's
going to be that big
of an impact in the
future of all businesses.
And we really think
that that's what's next,
right, this platform, this
collection of services,
this beautifully integrated
assembly of APIs that's
designed not just as individual
LEGO blocks that you have
to figure out, but a suite,
a connected experience that
allows you to take data,
bring it into your services,
and deliver it out to
customers, to build applications
faster than you
ever could before,
and to soundly host them on the
most rock-solid infrastructure
available in the world.
We think this is a place
where the future of technology
is being built, and that it's
being built by you together
with the engineers at Google.
What a great place to work.
What a great place to create.
I hope you take advantage
of the next several days.
We have a lot of
Google engineers here.
But we also have a lot
of incredible customers
and their engineers
in the audience.
Connect with each other in the
playground or in our hallways.
I think the sessions are going
to be very, very exciting, very
interesting.
I'm really looking forward
to hear from you what it
is you're going to build next.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
KENJI SHIOIRI
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
I hope that you enjoyed
the keynote presentations.
At the very end
in this morning, I
would like to recap what we want
to really communicate to you.
So GCP, what the unique
features about GCP?
So through GCP, what kind of
value does Google offer to you?
So that's something
which I hope that you
consider throughout the
presentation so far.
Well, GCP value is not just
of changing the location
to be offered with
servers or computers.
So what is the change?
GCP is changing the way
how computer is used,
and the computer is maybe the
businesses or organizations
or people.
Those aren't changing by
using Google Cloud Platform.
And that's the value of GCP.
Well, of course, BigQuery,
the huge volume of data
can be now dealt maybe
at a cheaper price, maybe
at faster speed.
Well, you feel your own way
about what kind of value
is most important to you.
But I hope that it's
a huge-- I think,
it's a huge challenge
for really everyone
to feel the value of GCP.
So we are committed to support
every single challenge which
all of you are facing,
not just in Japan, but all
over the globe.
So in what areas can we support
the enterprises or businesses?
One is innovation.
We offer innovation.
And also, our innovation is
not just occupied by Google.
Our technology is
all open source
so that it can be
offered to you.
Kubernetes is one
example open source.
As you see, the on-premise in
GCP and other cloud provider's
cloud, you can manage the
different environment,
or different clouds.
And you can actually
implement even today.
So open source technology
and also innovation
throughout the day, I
hopefully, you really
feel that open source or
technology innovation.
And for you, who do those
practice of the technology,
I'm sure that you need
a different support.
This year, we help you
to innovate the business.
So we offer the
professional services.
Well, any companies
who are going
to challenge to move
to cloud, or maybe you
already have expertise about
the different technology,
but you are new to Google.
Maybe the assessment
of consulting services
can be offered by our
professional service team.
And also, in terms of the
support, the Google Cloud
Platform vision, we already
have a global support team.
But in Asia, we have the
support location in Tokyo.
And all the support is
offered in Japanese.
We, of course, want to
improve the service levels.
And we want to really offer
more resources in this area.
Not just services which we
offer, but most importantly, we
have the great partners who
also offer the value to you.
So we think having
the great ecosystem
is really important for us,
so not just with partners,
but with communities.
CGP user group, or maybe the
BigQuery for BQ's [INAUDIBLE].
I think the different
communities is now established,
including GCP OG.
So these community also support
you to endeavour to the new
project using Google
Cloud Platform.
Also, maybe you hear
that new technologies,
or maybe you haven't really
experienced the Google
technologies yet.
And for those people, we
want to really enhance
our training services.
The Top Gate partner is the
certified training partners.
And through the
Top Gate, we want
to really have a
great program so
that you can catch up with
the cutting-edge technologies.
So I hope that we really
work with you to endeavour
into the new challenges
which you are facing now.
So for you to make
the initial step,
the $500 equivalent
credit can be offered.
And we are going to email
you, if you registered, $500.
You can actually dollars can
purchase quite a lot of time
for the micro-instances.
So if you think there is
any great services which
you may want to use, I hope
that you use these programs
so that you can make one step,
a first step for the greater
technologies.
Well, I think I heard
the different products,
or services, or customer cases,
uses cases in this morning.
But in the afternoon, we
have more detail sessions
going to a little bit deep
dive in the respective area.
So now, you are hearing all
those great technologies is
this morning keynote addresses.
I hope that you
continue the momentum
so that you can participate
in the different breakout
sessions.
Once again, thank you very
much for your participation.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]